for those of you who love Tick Tock and
solely rely on Tick Tock for your
content to go viral you may want to
listen to this video you may not like it
matter of fact you may not want to
listen to this video because it's going
to hurt a little bit but let me get into
it so I was very hesitant of getting on
Tick Tock I was convinced Tick Tock was
part of China bite dance and they had
certain things that were doing behind
closed doors I read all the articles I
read the disclaimer I read what they
stand stood for finally I said you know
what I don't care if I get kicked off a
tick tock I really want to find out if
there's any credibility behind all the
criticism that Tick-Tock get for those
of you who love Tick Tock and use it
regular and you love the app there's one
organization you cannot criticize God
forbid you do on Tick Tock you'll see
what happens to your numbers by the way
it's very important for you to watch
this video it's tough for some of you to
watch it but it's important for you to
watch this video because remember what
happened to vine there were all these
Vine celebrities oh my God 5 billion
views 10 million views Boom the app shut
down 80 of celebrities nobody knew about
afterwards six months 12 months later
took a lot for some people able to make
the adjustments you may want to know
what's happening with Tick Tock because
they're one president away from being
banned in no time so having said that
I'm going to share with you a social
experiment I did with my own account on
Tick Tock to see if this was true or not
and I have proof for you with pure data
and you'll be able to make a decision
for yourself so let's get right into it
[Music]
so before we get into the video a couple
things if you get value out of this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe to
the channel and if it makes you think
share it with others so two timetables
we measured on how videos we're doing
first one is from June 7 2022 to August
5th of 2022 which is roughly 264 clips
that were uploaded during that time on
Tick Tock then we looked at from August
6 2022 until November 23rd which are on
722 Clips were uploaded you're going to
see a major difference in numbers so
there's four category of videos we're
gonna break down first one is videos
getting between zero to twenty thousand
views second is video is getting between
20 to 100 000 views then a hundred
thousand two million and last but not
least at a million plus now why are we
looking at August 50s because August 5th
is when I uploaded a video criticizing
the one organization the one name you
cannot criticize on Tick Tock viewership
dropped 10 200 x you'll see 100x when I
show it to you and daily followership
used to be 50 000 to 75 followers on The
Tick Tock for three months straight
every month to down to three to five
thousand followers on a monthly basis so
when you look at the first round June 7
to August 5th here's what happened
videos between zero to twenty thousand
views were 99. videos between 20 to 100
000 views for 111 102 million 45 videos
got over a hundred thousand two million
views and nine videos got over a million
views now keep in mind this is when the
account was smaller I only had forty
thousand followers or eighty thousand
followers a hundred thousand followers
so I'm getting a million plus views on
videos on a very small account that I
just started because I didn't really
trust Tick Tock yet then boom on August
5th I upload a video criticizing China
this is what the video looked like
here's what the video was I put this
video up if you come out this strong and
your name is China
and you want to be the world leader you
cannot make a threat like this and not
deliver oh
which means
she has to know this Biden has to know
this we have to be on alert and we have
to know this isn't a small country
saying this this isn't a billionaire
saying this this is our number one enemy
in the world who wants to take over us
they had a vision called made in China
2025 it was by 2025 China wanted to be
the ruler of the World when they say
this you best believe behind closed
doors everybody needs to be ready for
this it almost looked like numbers
instantaneously change and my people
would come up to me at the office the
past something's going on with Tick Tock
I'm like guys stop with all this stuff
jump into conclusion no give it another
week give it another week give it
another week Pat look at the numbers
look at the comparison look I'm like I'm
telling you give it one more month Pat
look at the numbers finally after
looking all these numbers testing it's
showing it right next to each other I
said maybe the team's got a good
argument let's take a look at this
here's what happened after or I uploaded
that video about China so once again
between June 7 to August 50 was 264
videos we were measuring now we're going
to look at August 6th to November 23rd
722 so when you look at it side by side
here's what you see Zero to twenty
thousand views you ready
720 videos were only between 0 to 20 000
views you want to know how many videos
were twenty thousand two hundred
thousand views only two
one of them was a Buffett video and one
of them was an Antonio Brown video do
you want to know how many videos got
over a hundred thousand views two
million only one and you know how many
got over a million zero so let me get
this straight when the account was
smaller I got 111 videos to go between
20 to 100 000 when the channel is bigger
when the account is bigger on 720 videos
we're measuring only two got between 20
to 100 000. when the account was smaller
I got 45 to get to 100 to a million when
the accounts bigger only one get 100
over a million when the account's
smaller I get nine over a million when
the accounts bigger I get zero over a
million makes you think so so keep in
mind it's more clips
fewer opportunities over a hundred
thousand fewer Clips more over a hundred
thousand it's kind of like a hundred at
bats you're hitting 40 home runs for
example here a thousand at bats you're
hitting one home run very weird then I
said well let's look at the content to
see if it's getting better or worse
because maybe numbers are not grown on
all the other channels here's what we
noticed the last two or three months
have been the biggest month in the
history of our content ever on our all
our YouTube channels pbd podcasts by
Timmy shortclips pbd podcast just won
over around 430 000 Subs by Timmy
shortcuts just went over 400 000 Subs
you know you got value team just won
over 3.7 million Subs my Instagram
account just went over 3.4 million every
Twitter is growing everything's growing
except for one thing Tick Tock so let's
compare the clips maybe the content went
lower so look at the clips here same
Clips we uploaded on Instagram how many
views did they get versus the same Clips
we uploaded on Tick Tock here's the
results so here here's a clip I did
about buffets on Instagram 1.3 million
views on Tick Tock 20 000 views here's a
clip about Shaq on Instagram 1.5 million
Tick Tock 10 200. here's another one
about men their testosterone level going
lower 1 million versus Tick Tock 7 600.
here's another one 970 this was about
houses good time to buy 970 000 views
versus 15 000 views here's a video about
staying positive 3.9 million views on
Instagram only 5600 views on Tick Tock
here's one about reading books 1 million
views on Instagram 9 500 views on Tick
Tock here's about sales people 1.1
million on Instagram Tick Tock 12 900.
here's one about helping people 933 000
views versus 11.9 000 views here's one
about marriage on Instagram 9.6 million
views here's on Tick Tock 9600 views
that's a thousand times less so somebody
may say well on Instagram you have 3.4
million followers on Tick Tock you only
have 260. what's 260 times a thousand
times ten is 2.6 million times 100 is 26
6 million times a thousand is 260
million followers I don't have 260
million followers on Instagram the
numbers don't make sense let me continue
Michael burry 932 versus 12 900. Jewish
money 5.9 million versus 12 900. Rolex
3.1 million versus 16 600. Detroit 1
million versus eleven thousand art 1.1
million versus 9700 another Buffett
video 2 million versus seventeen
thousand nine hundred not having kids
1.2 million versus thirty two hundred
Tate 1.2 million versus twenty one
thousand seven hundred so now you saw
the data you get to make a decision 264
videos like the 722 like that why that
kind of that's kind of weird and then
the other content is doing better on
Insta and other places than it is on
Tick Tock and here's the other part I'm
not looking for you to say oh my God
poor Pat I have a great life I'm not
sitting here that I need sympathy
whatsoever I'm a leader I take
responsibility for the words that's
coming out of my mouth how to improve
how to adjust feed my mind that's all on
me I want you to hear from what other
experts have to say and influencers have
to say about this four names I'm going
to give to you one is musk the other one
is Scott Galloway Scott Galloway cannot
stand Elon Musk Scott Galloway said musk
will never buy Twitter he's just playing
with everybody he'll never cut the check
and every day Scott Galloway criticizes
musk on Twitter so they're not on the
same page what Rogan said what a
comedian Andrew Schultz said Andrew
Schultz said the best thing on one of
the podcast I'm paraphrasing what he
said he said the algorithm in China
benefits kids who are making things that
are interesting engineer creating
something it's getting them to be
smarter those videos go viral in China
but algorithms in U.S favor boys and
girls who do silly dumb [ __ ] to get
viral and get attention because they
want the reward in America to be do
stupid things to get recognized so the
algorithms are dumbing up the kids in
America they can do that because they
control the algorithm Scott Galloway
went on Tick Tock and said the following
he said there's no difference with the
CCP and a Chinese company a CO can
disappear for four weeks people under
the age of 18 are not spending more time
on Tick Tock than all the other apps
combined these are his words Tick Tock
needs to be banned full stop he said
that to Bill Maher and Bill Mars like
whoa whoa whoa Trump wasn't a fan even
Biden's not necessarily a big fan of
tick tock even though he's on it very
actively during the campaign here's what
musk said musk said Tick Tock is
destroyed civilization and a rogue gets
on his podcast and reads the entire
terms of service and people are saying
wait a minute is that really on the
terms and service yes it is said we
collect information about the device you
use to access the platforms such as your
IP address your region and user agent
mobile carrier time zone settings
identifiers for advertising purposes
model of your service device your device
system networks it keeps it says are you
kidding me they really track the way you
move your finger they track the way your
keystrokes which means they're trying to
find out everything about everything
you're doing this is a app that's
eventually going to get banned it's
banned already in Indonesia in
Bangladesh India ban Tick Tock it's
banned in Syria for different reasons
it's been in many different places and
very soon it's going to be banned in
America because they are manipulating
the way you are receiving content it's
just a matter of time so again like I
said earlier I wanted a test to see if
it was true about what Tick Tock and
bite dance the owner back in China
doesn't like to talk about they don't
like you when you criticize China and
when the CEO of tick tock U.S was on
court being asked questions do you have
to report everything to buy tents well
you know we we are we run in a very
separate way that's not my question do
you have to report everything back to by
test we run as a completely different
organization do you have to report
everything back
10 different ways the guy asked the
question finally said well essentially
yes we are owned by by tense and we yes
we have to report of course you do and
you think China loves America they don't
look
create the content you're going viral
but whatever you do if you are somebody
that's doing very very good things on
Tick Tock and it's working out for you
you have to have an outcome to get
everybody off of tick tock elsewhere
before that thing shuts down because it
doesn't have a long time to live in
America specifically what they're doing
and their motives neither the left the
right or the middle trusted I know the
younger generation is going to be
devastated but it's coming very very
soon you just added data comparing you
two days right how we were getting more
views now we don't what's the outcome of
me doing this video maybe asking
yourself do I need sympathy my gosh Pat
I'm gonna go watch your videos on Tick
Tock you get views you think this is
going to change you think someone at
tick tock's gonna potentially see this
and say hey let's pump up their videos
to go get some movies it's not going to
happen why is that I'm doing this I got
four kids we're having conversations
right now about phones one of my my 10
year old kid were talking about phones
what's gonna happen if this guy gets a
phone he goes to school Everyone's
Watching Tick Tock what's he gonna
duplicate same thing so let me get this
straight when they came out with the
Patriot Act I've interviewed a lot of
mobsters a lot of people who the
governments somehow was able to wiretap
and see what they're doing but the
Patriot Act allowed the government to do
so without your permission to listen to
what you're doing to surveillance what
you're doing to wiretap you pretty much
lose all your freedom so but that's the
gov your government doing it to you now
imagine a government who doesn't like
your country is an enemy of yours is not
why you're tapping everything you're
doing and incentivizing videos that
criticize capitalism incentivizing
videos that criticize America
incentivizing videos that criticize
marriage and incentivizing videos that
criticize why America is the greatest
country in the world and an incentive I
think woke ideology right oh my gosh all
these weird victimhood mentality you
don't think that's a way to hurt an
entire civilization a country especially
a country they think China goes to sleep
saying wow America's such a wonderful
country leading the way for the rest of
us because we so much love America they
don't I lived in a country for 10 years
that said hate upon America every day on
the news so you you best believe there
are some countries that do not like
America and China being at the top of
the list they're not doing this because
they want to make billions with Tick
Tock and make the most expensive app of
all time they're doing it because they
know once they get a hold of your 10
year old kid your 12 year old kid your
14 year old kid and your kids spend
hours on top of hours on this without
being in front of you this thing and
Tick Tock has more influence over your
kids than you do game over you lose your
kid for kids for 10 20 years if you want
that that's why I'm doing this video you
make a decision for yourself whatever
you want to do with Tick Tock FYI
I'm still gonna keep posting videos on
Tick Tock you know why because I'm in
the conversion mindset I'm in the
mindset of getting people to think for
themselves to say you can stand up you
can take personal responsibility you can
do big things for your life and let them
say I'm not gonna let anybody see
because if one person gets shifted and
one person says I'm gonna lead I'm so
sick of this [ __ ] ftx's uh mom
writes a article for Stanford years ago
in 2013 saying we have to get rid of
personal responsibility because this
this thing doesn't make any sense look
what the sun does the Apple doesn't fall
far from the tree China wants to see
more stories like Sam bankman free
because they want that guy to be the
hero to young kids we don't want that
we're going to do our part and we're
going to keep leading and those who
listen would eventually have a massive
Army together to make sure freedom of
speech free enterprise all of those
freedoms that you fought for and other
people fought for it's around for people
like you and I and our kids if you're
for that give it a thumbs up and share
this video with others and subscribe to
the channel if you think this is a
message worthy of being shared with
others if you enjoyed this video I got
another one I want you to watch it's a
video titled the rise of weak men if
you've not watched it click here to
watch it take care everybody bye
[Applause]
[Music]